city
3000 feet
before the video starts guys check our
sponsors and nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10% of
their products what are you guys waiting
for
Salaam alaikum where I'm at today better
care to Berlin citizen dear friends hope
you guys awareness all that welcome to
this video but first I want to place a
lotta panatela the most merciful the
most just or previous glory and
gratitude belong to him for the work
that we do at Salaam studios now welcome
today's specific show would have a name
for it as usual were just discussing
some current affairs and things that's
been happening and now we had this is
quite interesting okay this is why
interesting and we're gonna discuss some
deep stuff rapper juice yeah juice WL
wrld are the next that stands for world
has passed away
he had a fit and in an airport in
Chicago Airport and he passed away now
in 2017 a rapper called lil peep
I think that's what's the name is in
2018 xxx ten shades and chases 10 shades
or something like that long that name
until I was 18 he died in 2019 this year
brother cadet who was a rapper himself
was involved in an accident and he died
as well and also in 2019 and ended this
year a juice the rapper juice died now
what can we learn from this this is
actually very key and one thing that's
why actually interest in this Mac it's a
self proclaimed prophecy so fulfill
prophecy self-fulfilled prophecy now
watch this video which I don't encourage
you guys to watch it but I'm just gonna
play it in mute inshallah
and yeah so here we go there's no
anything I'm stuck in there like a woman
etcetera so here we go this time it was
unexpected okay this is Triple X
tenacious if I'm not mistaken that's him
he passed away so in his rap tune yeah
which I'm not gonna mention the name
hopefully well he mentions the death of
this rapper last time it was the drugs
he was lacing this is low peep a fan of
infamous taking it he died is well I
think of an overdose
all old legends fall in the making now
this is interesting here because now
he's talking about you know people that
he knew and he believes all legends fall
in the making you have this or he claims
there and he's just basically
reminiscing and you know you know just
remembering these people so it's not a
tribe tribute to them and so Hana Wow
look at this
sorry truth dying young demon youth yeah
I don't know that mean
now look at this carefully guys listen
to this carefully what's the 27 club
yeah I don't know what he means by that
yeah
maybe he's talking about a group of
people who died at the age of 27 we
ain't making it past 21 I've been going
through paranoia yeah it's always got to
keep a gun acceptable that's a lifestyle
you live you live by the gun you die by
the gun now let's rewind oh yeah damn
the world you live in now okay okay so
let's go back a bit
yeah okay let's go back a bit this is
and this is what people are claiming
yeah he it's like we ain't making it
past 21 yeah he died at the age of 21 I
think they say in a couple of days
before his birthday yeah now Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala knows best did he know
about did he just say that but what is
profound is that when you look at these
rappers yep and you look at their deaths
this is a reminder to us you know why
because look how I lost upon what I was
picking people that I've got massive
reach this video is 39 million people
just that video alone God knows how many
videos he's done and through other
platforms as well millions and billions
of people are watching these people and
there are people taken from it
what are we learning from this what do
we learn from this these rappers that we
are looking up to that we think they
live in the life or whether maybe most
of the times if you look at them they
are actually going through like some
kind of a depression yet they are going
through some kind of issues
so if I open this video so this guy this
himself juice yep he died right at the
age of 21 if you guys last hour I know
people think that you know that he's you
know he's living a it's all about and
most of the time these rappers themself
either commit suicide drug overdose now
why'd you need to take drugs yet and all
of them have to go and take drugs before
they can perform why because they are
suffering from depression because you
need to understand when your goals are
finite when you reach them in this life
you've got nothing else to do like Mike
Tyson was saying in one interview
because once I believed Klitschko the
Austin was nixed he said depression is
mix because your goals are finite and
when you reach them that's it what's
next but when we have up goes infinite
that is something that we have to work
on till the day we die and inshallah
instead of Hereafter so you can see
sometimes with this video himself but
sometimes you see like they they are
lost
yeah so brothers and sisters I said in
this in a different video as well that
the reason why allah subhanho wa taala
does not tell us when we're gonna die is
because for this very reason we should
live like we're going to die we should
live like we're going to die tomorrow
you see people can perceive this and
understand this phrase in two ways
number one do as much fun as you can
have as much fun as you can do whatever
you can because you only live once
go there get it live it as much as you
can because you're gonna die once a
believer a Muslim will look at this and
say I've got one chance man I've got one
chance and I need to make the most out
of this and this is what he will do and
this how we will act and if you go to my
video about the videos I did about why
Andy Roos lost a beautiful reminder of
why he lost and how we will lose in the
hereafter and there's a connection
between him and what happened so let's
inshallah understand that this life is
nothing but a test when you're going to
go you don't know and there's a reason
why Allah hasn't told you when you're
going to go cuz it's a test you're gonna
have your ups and downs but it's
struggling their stride
because this is not going to bring you
happiness you know it and I know it mm
17 18 19 little peep xxx attention 10
chases and juice yeah and cadet as well
and under cadets name handler we raised
money to for water will and this is on
the screen you can see this one
inshallah now this is the water well and
we're going to have people making dois
and we want him to benefit however he
died as a Muslim and we can do something
as I said Bacardi and we tried to do
that in genre and you can see that
brothers and sisters work for your hair
after be prepared one lie if I told you
guys that I have an investment
opportunity for you guys a house a
mercedes-benz s-class you will do
everything in your power to get this I
said it's ten thousand pounds only you
would call friends family you would even
think it's a fraud just cam why because
it's too good to be true yeah and those
of you who believe in it will act
towards getting it brothers and sisters
think a millionaires ahead
I lost the panel time is offering
something greater so inshallah please
learn from this is relish Allah don't
take these people as some kind of a role
model why because eventually they have
left this world without even knowing he
did they did but me I don't know yeah
himself decision is rock music we don't
know alice is not an and hair cutter
careful had to more macabre Keller
sulphate Anna moon boom McCandless
outfit on a moon competition in the
worldly life increase and diverts you
yeah until you visit the graves know you
are going to know this is a last talking
no certainty no you're going to know
then know you are going to know you are
surely going to know know if you only
knew with knowledge of certainty bothers
and sisters we are all amazed by this
warty things and that's why it's
recommended that we go to the graveyard
sometimes and there was a scholar who
said something profound they asked him I
said why do you never come and sit with
us and you always end the graveyards he
said when I sit with you guys all you do
is back by other
and when I leave you're competitive when
I leave you guys probably gonna back by
me and one of you when I'm with you guys
chillin with you guys
you remind me off this dunya because
when I go to the graveyards
most people don't back by me never give
it back by others and they remind me of
the hair after brothers and sisters have
companions that remain to remind you of
the hereafter go to the graveyard don't
depress yourself oh every now and then
it's just a reminder it's just the check
you know because indeed a reminder
benefits a believer remind yourself
before it's too late
so next time assalamu alaikum